hallo erstmal also live vom bau zeigt
euch live unzensiert
was hier gerade geschieht also mehr noch
wenn hier irgendjemand auf dem bau ist
der keine arbeitsgenehmigung hat der
irgendwie unterhalt bezahlen muss und
irgendwie schwarzarbeit wird die alle
die räume verlassen
wie gesagt wir arbeiten hier gerade wie
die jungs zusammen machen den ganzen bau
hier fertig es ist ein leises bau update
was ich nach jetzt einfach so hoch laden
werde
und jetzt kommen was die show macht das
schauspiel macht die stroh komplett
technik so und zwar wird es so einsicht
beton estrich gesicht pdf sich beton
optik wir sind nachher aussieht optik
heißt eigentlich schön aus aber soll hat
so seine chance ich ein künstler hat
drei jahre lang in dem bergdorf im
kaukasus verbracht und hat sie das alles
hier angeeignet es lässt sich struck op
was er macht und italien japan italien
es ist ein ort wo im vulkan ausgebrochen
ist und wo die ganze stadt unter sich
begraben hat und daher kommt der name
weil da nämlich vulkangestein drin ist
richtig richtig ok genau und die jungs
hier die machen die decke und zwar die
decke wird auch ein industries tage
macht die ohnehin kein haftgrund drauf
machen und nach dem sinn hauptgrund
drauf gemacht dass hier
da las gerade das tut ist gerade innen
drin verspachteln dass wir nachher
darüber streichen könnte es gibt sich
richtig viel mühe
ja und hier auch und es wird nachher die
küche und die küche ihr seht es ist
schon so ein fries sollen küchen
freestyle mir eingelassen haben und hier
werden nachher die fliesen gelegt und da
wo dies dieses graue ist ist nachher die
die küchen arbeitsplatten und am
mittwoch kommt die küche ist rein und
deswegen machen wir jetzt die ganzen
wenn die touren die verspachteln richtig
künstlerisch und dann haben wir hier die
kaffeemaschine und will die
kaffeemaschine sieht so dass die
kaffeemaschine wir haben wirklich eine
kaffeemaschine ihren drei becher für 15
leute deswegen sprechen auch epidemien
ausbrechen eigentlich aus in einer auf
einer baustelle
wenn alle drei alle 15 leute aus drei
bechern trinken da hat der schiene folie
darüber gemacht und zwar immer folien
codiert das nachher jeden sich vögel zu
sehen ist nicht jemand brauchen sollte
man schauen sie das richtig drauf in
meinem nächsten leben werde ich immer
schon werden die ersten sohn wo ich habe
nicht ja ich höre ihr seid alle zählen
wenigen sohn habe nicht im ski auf jeden
fall richtig cool und da geht es jetzt
richtig voran die jungs machen ist echt
toller sie muss ehrlich sagen ganz ganz
tolle junge handwerker handwerker sind
etwas ganz ganz besonderes
wir sind echt toll und oderberg der bahn
endlich der erste kläger laken richtig
tollen estrich gemacht dann zeige ich
euch mal kurz sind zeigen euch mal ganz
trotz der estrich der band gelegt hat
ist ein ganz besonderer wurden
das macht nicht jeder
und zwar ist es ich zeichne ich hole mir
das nicht so sieht es nachher aus so
sieht der boden raus das ist so eine
sicht beton estrich auch am boden das
ist jetzt immer nicht die band brachten
aber richtig genial gemacht und deswegen
abgedeckt dass da nichts passiert und
der bewerber macht normalerweise auch
diese wand technik der macht auch diese
man täglich berichtigt kugel das
dankeschön oder weber ich will nicht
noch weiter was zeigen aber wie gesagt
in den coups entschuldigung ich komme
gleich in den räumen geht es auch weiter
es geht also ich denke schon zwei
monaten müsste man spätestens drin sein
dann haben wir hier schon mal hier ist
als boxen kabel und smart home system
und die boxen kann das heißt jeder raum
hat hier wirklich boxen ist auch richtig
gut gemacht und hier ist immer in der
garage
da kam das garagentor jetzt auch rein
hier mit dem licht wand und hier werden
wir so do it yourself videos machen
endlich und hier wurde auch schon
verputzt und die wände werden noch mit
zum klinker gemacht also richtig cool
doch und hier seht ihr auch hier wurde
auch schon verputzt nicht der eingang
von uns später
und hier läuft es ganz schön laut und
wie gesagt die ganzen länder müssten
hier noch trocken und so weit sind auch
am samstag kommt ein gutes bau abnehmen
wenn er da mal reinschauen möchte und da
zeigt es sich um einige sachen und wir
müssen das wirklich beeilen auf die
ganzen kilometerweise kabel gelegt bin
ganz ganz tolle geschichte und hier auch
vorbereitung auf elektromobilität ein
ganz ganz großes thema wir haben keine
elektrofahrzeuge werde man demnächst
auch nicht haben weil sie einfach noch
zu teuer sind
aber du musst jetzt schon beim bau schon
kann denken was passiert in der zukunft
und besser ist jetzt schon zu machen
als später noch schnitzereien zu klopfen
ja wie gesagt ich mache zwei auf der
baustelle die sally kommt grad bringt
was zu essen und dann geht es hier
weiter
es muss mal kurz fragen ist ja ist hier
irgendjemand veganer keiner veganer
alles da dann gibt es die jungs dann
noch immer noch also keine keine keine
veganer hier also jungs dann kann alles
kommen jetzt so jetzt kommt das essen
ist die wcs schon und wir sind kräftig
am bauen und was ich mir noch ganz
zeigen würde ist folgendes natürlich
noch ganz kurz hoch das zeige ich auch
noch kurz die treppen hoch das ist aus
dieser song orange kurz und zwar kommt
hier auch schon die gewollte
schwiegereltern ist auch schon mal hier
kürzt immer hoch
jungs ist ja jemand veganer seid ihr
veganer okay dann jetzt kommt noch okay
also keiner veganer nein also ich habe
er habe sich nämlich gerecht jemand
legal auf dem bau ist aber okay der
döner kommt und jungs die bauliche die
kirche von der mama auch im total aus
der puste
und solltest landhaus sich um eine ganz
tolle geschichte und schaut euch mal
bitte diese fließen dann nicht fliesen
platten und zwar hier kann ich zeigen
aber ich zeige dass da hinten guck mal
hier kann ich euch zeigen schaut euch
mal diese via platten an ganz genial
und wie gesagt die jungs kann hier schon
an und später soll sie jetzt im moment
hinaus aber wir geben uns mühe dahin
habt ihr so gesehen diese flecken an den
wänden sind risse die wir schon bekommen
haben jetzt ist aber nicht schlimm
die haben wir da mit amir aufgemacht und
netz und haben sie dazu gemacht also
richtig cool werden
kommst du mal kurz mal ganz kurz die
küche an wo die fließen also wie gesagt
wir hören uns und am samstagabend bei
update und ihr könnt euch jetzt mal
anschauen
hier ist der kühlschrank schon hier sind
armaturen richtig cool alles nach also
macht's gut und wir hören uns und wir
sehen uns und am samstag beim bauamt
einschalten cool bis dahin tschüss